Well, you will a person get the same benefit using decaf coffee with coffee
animals. The answer is yes and no. So some people have a sensitivity to
caffeine and they just cannot do caffeine coffee animals. They absorb it real
quickly and they just get wired and then they can't sleep. What are the solutions
if that is the case is to do your coffee animals in the morning, not at night.
Secondly, if you're absorbed the fluid of the coffee animal too fast, it
isn't a possible side that you're dehydrated. So you're absorbed in your
larger test of the fluid including the caffeine. That is part of the issue. So you
might want to investigate that. Other people just have a sensitivity to
caffeine, the general can't drink caffeine at all. And it does have to do with a
specific gene that you don't detoxify caffeine well at all. So they can't
drink caffeine, caffeine, coffee or caffeinated beverages. They just don't do well
with those and I understand that. Those people we have suggested to do
cavernal meal animals, cavernal meal tea just making cavernal tea and do that. You
can do decaffeinated coffee animals. Even decaffeinated coffee still has
some caffeine in it. Make sure you use a water decaffeinated coffee, not a chemical
decaffeinated coffee. However, when you don't have caffeine in whatever you're
using for an animal, whether you're doing an animal with a tea or a lower
caffeinated product with the decaffe coffee, you're not going to get as great
a stimulation of the parasympathetic. So that's really the whole focus of the
coffee animal. So yes, it does make a difference when you're using something
without caffeine or something decaffeinated with lower caffeine. The whole idea
with the coffee animal coffee that we use, the gold rose coffee, is that it's a
higher level of caffeine because the higher level of caffeine stimulates the
parasympathetics more effectively. So it's really the caffeine that's
stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system. So yeah, you are losing some of that
benefit. So do investigate, you know, the reason why you don't want to use the
caffeine is because you're dehydrated or as it's just because of the sensitivity to
the coffee, the decaffeinated one.